hello and welcome to this video playing
meander [ __ ] meander book movie 5 now
this is not really great but it leads to
really wacky positions they've lost the
tournament game once again sis opening
which was very frustrating
yeah I'm trying to push the the bishop
back I'm not sure if I could have
punished g6 and in the stronger fashion
I don't know I'm quite happy with my
position but maybe I could have done
something even more powerful don't know
at that plate basically you play me in
the same way as you playing as one
before I go before take b5 that is the
strongest way to play against this b5
setup okay d6 y and here d5 looks like
the most normal choice but what is this
next move
what is the next move probably not be d7
which after which would be 5 d5 looked
even better stuff the same wood loved
him to improve the Queen position a
little bit but I don't really have a
good way to do that ok I'm going to just
make a medium move
or does he have no this one okay 90th
form what you really good to see 60 M
threatening bishops e6 now I'm he more
or less has to take than a for Bishop
and I don't think he's in terrible shape
if he does so I'm not super happy with
my result here of this of the scheme
yeah Bishop c6 or something that he
should have prevented I think why is
Bishop c8 now somehow a good move
okay so he 7 is hanging
I don't know I also have before all
right just push this back ok fatigue is
7 now takes 90 X and before it's covered
so would be 7 the only thing I dislike
level said I have a couple of
unprotected pieces don't really see how
he makes use of it but I see 3 is not
protected the bishop is not protected
looks a bit loose but again I don't see
him yeah this is this is one of the
moves that I thought could be possible
the rook crown is a bit short of squares
really is short of squares overtake and
this is also hanging
did you slow him okay okay the rook has
still no squares but taking a knight c6
is oftentimes probably quite good before
and see who were saying okay I have to
be quicker I really have to be quicker
maybe I can actually
King taking us no good okay time is
ticking down
quindi 896 extremely hot line
yeah Queen D 896 takes takes it's
probably okay
yes so what is he doing here this is six
have no clue 28 still looks like no I
don't know what this does what is that
doing 93 or what against this no this
one and how c4 is saying oh my goodness
I'm completely blundering in all of the
same I have no time ie one is hanging
completely I should okay what is this
this is the worst game ever
97 would be cool don't see it working
though
Queen takes g6 is almost possible oops I
completely lost the plot but there was a
really really weird game I completely
lost control over this position which
was like around here just over
yeah anyhow let's check this a little
bit um yeah this is how you play this
look e1 g6 that was surprising really
maybe I should not play with c4 now and
rather d4 as the engine suggests quicker
development the main issue with blacks
players is very much lagging in
development he plays the bishop quite
often I mean this is not bad but also
not super convincing should be 596 the
d5 now was already quite yeah what what
it's what you normally do but I wasn't
entirely certain about it
it's got c6 and yeah but justice is so
going to be better for me yeah I wanted
to wait until he placed this and only
then D 5 so that my controller with 94
bishop c6 is stronger of this is 6
squared Knight b6 is the move that I had
not really appreciated he didn't play it
but here there's c6 and hmm I mean I'm
okay but nothing special
yeah 95 94 looked difficult and now I
was shocked that he didn't take on a
forces totally mandatory to take I mean
of course you want to take this Bishop I
mean okay and here I'm better but it's
not it's not the end of the world and
not coming to c6 you can simply take
yeah Ruby 8 bishop c6 is pretty awful
quincy a druggie sell or before and Ruby
7
should be winning right yeah more lesson
95 and probably now I need to improve it
a little bit okay this is still fine
and now 96 okay that makes a lot of
sense actually because taking this is
very powerful it's very powerful just
winning recipe okay we could be three
didn't seem to be terrible either
and now we'll be 5/4 stronger than 96
okay then it's understandable if we look
at this and whether it's a big threat
and something like that is the Knights
are just fantastically strong and
material wise it's okay I've got a big
pawn I mean all three I've got a pawn
and this year
four against to in effect very nice okay
I went to age four and now Knight H
Firefox right yeah it's not very
intuitive
okay you played this night
yeah night C fire of course I totally
over not and then here ignite c4 looks
devastating totally devastated
completely lost control over this
position even just a three years good
yeah of course yeah after this I have
Queen e2 or c2 whatever it's just us to
save I don't know I completely lost lost
the plot it's six
right here it's not the winning again
yeah what did we get game it really
weird Kim yeah okay guys thanks for
watching